what exactly is a stem cell the whole
idea of the stem cell was it can help to
regenerate or repair damaged tissue and
so the concept of repairing tissue is
very exciting because instead of having
to cut things out or instead of been
having to take drugs to manage symptoms
you can actually repair tissue we're
primarily using umbilical core stem
cells but there are different types of
stem cells you can even get them from
your bone marrow from your fats all the
tissue that comes after birth so that's
like placenta amniotic fluid umbilical
cord tissue and umbilical cord blood so
there's all these products that used to
just get thrown away but now we don't
throw them away we actually collect them
we manufacture we isolate the stem cells
and then we can distribute and sell them
and we inject them and use them for all
sorts of things